the illegal immigrant who became the
center the sanctuary city debate has
just reached with a complaint this time
against the federal government
Hosea Nez Garcias errata was acquitted
last year of murdering Kate Steinle in
San Francisco the jury concluding that
he shot her accidentally it was a
stunning verdict to some now sera T's
attorneys are accusing the US government
of acting quote with vindictive
prosecution end quote after getting hit
with a second set of charges they are
arguing quote this hi this case was
highly publicized both locally and
nationally almost immediately after the
death of Miss teen Lee then-presidential
candidate Donald Trump began to use mr.
Garcia's arathi as the symbol of the
dangerous illegal immigrants constitute
and the need for a wall between the
United States and Mexico end quote
what do you make of this yeah I know the
attorney who's bringing this forward J
Tony Sara from being a prosecutor in San
Francisco having cases there against him
he's a very principled guy he's really a
true believer beyond so this is exactly
this is his jam he likes he's like yes
so I'm not surprised that he's bringing
it this is the type of stuff that he
likes to take on that's novel he's using
like vindictive prosecution and trying
to bring in President Trump it's been a
lot of that lately would they try and
bring in the president and say oh the
president has you know made that
polluted this atmosphere in the
environment made it unfair to get a fair
trial because of the comments that he
has made or his activity on Twitter etc
so they've used the power of the
president's rhetorical you know
persuasion as an argument to say that it
has deprived somebody of you know a fair
trial or in this case saying there's
vindictive prosecution going forward I
don't think that it will prevail but
thank you for the question you're
welcome your honor Jesse what do you
make of I mean Kimberly's probably right
he's an excellent attorney and he got
this guy off which I thought it was a
slam-dunk case the prosecution did a
terrible job they overcharged they
should have gone with the manslaughter
instead of the murder one but it's a
showboat type of deal I mean this is a
Hail Mary it's not going to work
remember
when they held the press conference
after the acquittal and they've started
blaming President Trump and started to
nationalize the story this is just a
local story the guy should have been
locked up and now call it vindictive or
not he broke federal law you cannot be
in the possession of a firearm if you're
an illegal immigrant
that's a 10-year mandatory that's what
they're trying to hit him with and good
I hope they I hope he's punished he
deserves to be punished the guy was I
think it was a meth head
he'd been in across the border five to
six times convicted of multiple felonies
and whether it was an accidental
shooting or was a purposeful shooting he
cost Kate Steinle her life and he should
pay the price for it and it's just sad
to see the whole thing trivialize in the
court like that so Dana the point that I
thought would interest you is that the
lawyers are in fact siding president
Trump's comments during the campaign and
his tweets as the basis for saying that
the president is the one who
nationalized this case and made sera T
into a subject of derision
I would also say you know he wasn't the
first to politicize end of nationalize
it I mean there was a lot of publicity
about this case and we know where that
all started and and and for good reason
because it was outrageous that she lost
her life and that the family is it going
to have to spend their life missing her
and being so heartbroken about it so if
he was acquitted the first time in some
ways I feel like they should just be
thankful for that and I guess we'll see
what happens in this next case the
they've tried to use president Trump's
tweets before like in the travel ban
case and it wasn't successful because
they said it wasn't material to the
thing so I don't know what will happen
in this case I doubt it will be
something you can specifically pin on
President Trump because everyone was
talking about it and it didn't start
with Trump what do you predict great
I don't not in the business of
predicting pontificating and I will say
if this was a political prop or a ploys
so what that's been the liberal strategy
with every crisis never let a scandal a
crisis go to waste they always know when
to find a poster boy and run with it and
this guy was this was a symbol of what
Donald Trump was talking about which is
the
a system that does not follow the law
allows for the pain and suffering of
lawful citizens and you know this it
illustrated it to such a degree that I
think it actually it helped elect him I
really think this would helped elect him
but the bigger point is there are four
things that have happened in the last
couple of years that kind of all have
something in common there's this case
there's parkland there's a there was a
killing in Boston where a madman had
stabbed a woman to death in a library
that was a couple of weeks ago there was
a teenager that just murdered his friend
at a slumber party after preaching to
Isis all of these things have in common
are that they people knew about them
beforehand they were known as dangerous
or problems by law enforcement
meaning all four of these kids these
horrible things including this guy could
have been prevented if people had
followed the law if they had followed
the law this guy wouldn't have been in
San Francisco even if it was an accident
and he was shooting at the ground and
the bullet ricocheted yeah that he
didn't mean to kill her but he never
would have been there if they follow the
law Donald Trump was elected because he
was talking about a return to law that's
why this was such a symbol and why it
worked you know don't you think it was
about immigration and and I mean what
what President Trump did I think quite
effectively was make him into the symbol
of the idea that boy there are a lot of
illegal immigrants who are criminals
well yeah he was legal immigrant who's a
criminal yeah well yeah but that's but I
think he was trying to say writ large
that's I don't think he was saying rent
large I think he was saying bad guys go
good guy stay yeah that's the way I read
it anyway that hombres remember yeah how
can I forget I'm not a mind-reader one I
love the Liberals okay